what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
you know one of the youtubers out there
who inspired me to become a youtuber
myself was a guy named hutch Shawn zero
seven to eight I think is his channel
you guys should go check him out because
he's actually pretty awesome awesome if
you did any please call duty but he kind
of inspired me to become a youtuber
myself so it'd be cool if you guys check
that out but anyway we are covering JLA
earth to not to be confused with the new
52 earth 2 story which is also really
really good and we'll start that when
the Justice League movie comes out fun
fact normally Sunday's are our Green
Lantern days but we'd be kind of
foolhardy not to cover Justice League
stuff with the Justice League movie
coming out so we're kind of postponing
brightest day and then joining back into
it once we're done with our Green
Lantern stuff but JLA earth 2 is a
really really cool story but here's what
I want you guys to do I want you guys to
imagine that DC is not publishing
anything right now I want you guys to
wind your minds back to the year 2000 so
there's no new 52 there's no DC rebirth
none of that stuff at the time this
story is written in the year 2000 DC
exists in two forms
there's pre-crisis DC and post-crisis DC
now pre-crisis DC introduced a lot of
different concepts different universes
things like that the one we're gonna be
talking about in this video is earth 3
home of a group called the crime
syndicate of america now the way this
story picks up is it initially just
basically sees the arrival of what looks
like Lex Luthor but it's not actually
Lex Luthor that we're familiar with
which is to say the evil guy who is the
arch-nemesis of Superman instead this is
just a Lex Luthor from a different
dimension this picks up with just the
superheroes of the DC Universe being
superheroes but they're a rival or I
guess really their action kind of
coincides with the arrival of a plane
that basically just appears out of thin
air more or less the problem is that
once they get onboard the plane once
they try to get everybody back down to
safety as they normally do the end of
finding out everybody on board is dead
and as they go through and they look at
the flight reporter they end up finding
out that Lex Luthor is in some form or
fashion tied into it and that's when we
start finding out the basis behind the
nature of this version of Lex Luthor the
coolest thing about this is that Lex
basically takes off you he goes to his
main base you know back to Lex Corp and
he's doing all kinds of generous things
that we normally never see giving people
pay raises not being jerks to people you
know it's really interesting to see like
how he functions in this capacity
because he's a genuinely good guy but
because of the fact that Lex Luthor has
historically been a
villain of Superman even if he is doing
charitable things the belief of Superman
of Martian Manhunter of Wonder Woman of
Cowell reign of the Green Lantern is
that there's some kind of an ulterior
motive and that's what he basically says
I'm not the Lex Luthor that you know I
am a person named Alexander Luthor and
that's the difference here now this
brings an to the equation the whole idea
of what this place is and how it
functions and exactly how it works now
if we jump back to this other version of
Earth and again we'll make sense of all
this stuff I'm not gonna leave you guys
in the dark and we're not gonna be
ambiguous this whole video but we jump
back to this alternate version of Earth
and we end up having a version of
Superman with a u on its chest
this is ultraman kind of weird to see
this where he's basically just dumping
fake money to everybody and where they
believe it's true they're kind of
relishing in this idea of free cash but
when they start to figure out that it's
false and one of them bad-mouths
ultraman ultraman uses heat vision to
incinerate this guy and that's the
importance of this is because this gives
us this dark version of Superman now in
the pre-crisis DC which basically DC
between when it first popped up in 1938
more or less running up to 1985 in 1960
the Justice League was by and large the
most popular team they'd ever put
together now the Justice League was not
the first time that a team composed of
superheroes had ever banded together and
then fought against bad guys for DC
itself it's most popular superhero team
before the Justice League was the
Justice Society of America and the JSA
was basically a team composed of
superheroes who were struggling more or
less to sell their own comics as well as
those who were definitely selling their
own comics you saw things like Hawkman
you saw like the flash Jay Garrick so on
and so forth but it was a team of
superheroes that came together to fight
crime in 1960 because of the fact that
DC had experienced this sort of second
Renaissance of comic-book interests
because of the fact that science fiction
comics were so popular superheroes were
fading and so DC blended superheroes and
science fiction together in the form of
the origin story of Barry Allen the
flash because of the fact that this
whole idea was so wildly popular in 1960
under I think the Julius Schwartz and I
believe they were created by Otto bender
the Justice League was created now the
idea was that the Justice League had
Batman as Superman in the title but it
was funny because DC realized and they
knew the Batman is Superman with a
one-two punch there were the two most
popular characters they were publishing
at the time and much like the original
JSA the Justice League was designed to
the profile of characters who are not
Batman or Superman
and it worked I mean it was hugely
popular when it came out it was insane
it was a license to print money it was
crazy how popular it was it really was
up until like Marvel came along and then
it raised the profiles of both companies
even higher because now fans had
competition so it was cool but the whole
idea was that in 1964 because of the
fact that the Justice League was so
popular DC sat down and asked the
question they said but what if the
Justice League was evil and that's where
the crime syndicate came into play the
crime syndicate comes from a place
called Earth 3 but that's where
Alexander Luthor comes from because on
earth 3 the way it was in the pre-crisis
continuity it was basically the opposite
Lex Luthor was a good guy the
superheroes were bad guys the problem
was that when crisis on Infinite Earths
happened in 1985 DC had to find a way to
basically bring these concepts back
without using the multiverse because the
mostly versa didn't exist between 1985
and 2006 with Infinite Crisis you just
had one universe and so DC had to say ok
we had these characters that originated
from the multiverse before crisis on
Infinite Earths but like how do we
explain their origins now and so the
cool thing about this is that this sees
the return of the crime syndicate for
the first time following the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths and so what
Alexander Luthor basically says is that
while this is a singular universe that
exists here he comes from a place called
the antimatter universe now in truth
this is just Grant Morrison being Grant
Morrison and what I mean by that is
after crisis on Infinite Earths Grant
Morrison came on board and he'd been
writing before that buddy came on board
as a guy who did like a lot of huge
things after crisis on Infinite Earths
DC got rid of the Justice League in
their traditional form instead we got
Justice League International and that
ran you know for a while under like
Keith Giffen and JM DeMatteis they
eventually left the title didn't perform
as well as it did under their writing
and artistry and so as a result DC
brought the JLA back in 1998 and Grant
Morrison was the one who wrote it and
fans loved it that's where you get
stories like Tower of Babel Morrison was
basically given a license to just kind
of do whatever he want to this alongside
stories like DC 1 million all-star
Superman this was really just one of
these things where he could just kind of
do whatever he wanted to do but the
whole idea here is him basically saying
well the antimatter universe exists out
there somewhere is just this universe
worst antimatter and that's just kind of
it now one of the things that throws
people off is the nature of the stories
and some of the things that Alexander
Luther says Alexander Luthor refers to
the earth of the superheroes the
Superman Batman the good guys were
reading about right now he refers to
them as earth - that is not meant to be
taken in a literal sense is not meant to
say that DC is referring to this as
earth - it's just it's how Alexander
Luthor views it but him showing up with
this fantastic tale of do we have
basically versions of you on my earth
but they have different names like owl
man and power ring and superwoman and
they're basically evil and they
conquered my world nobody really
believes it right off the bat
Batman above all others is just like
this is utter nonsense like it's it's
it's funny to see how Batman responds
because it's typical Batman but also
keep in mind here that one of the the
aspects of Superman whether it's a
failing whether it's what makes him a
great superhero is his willingness to
give people the benefit of the doubt and
his argument is well at the very least
let's just hear him out let's put it to
a vote and let's go to his reality and
see whether or not that's the case and
so what they end up agreeing on is that
a bulk of the Justice League will go to
this antimatter universe where the crime
syndicate is but Aquaman and Martian
Manhunter are going to stay behind one
of the first people were introduced to
is owl man and it's actually a really
cool concept so how a man asks you is
reintroduced here and again we're
ignoring all the new 52 stuff
owl man as he was introduced here is
basically Thomas Wayne jr. now one thing
to keep in mind is that in this crime
syndicate world things unfolded in
radically different ways in the main DC
Universe Thomas and Martha Wayne were
killed in a mugging gone wrong by a guy
named Joe Chill Bruce Wayne was just
stuck without any parents he swore
revenge and eventually became Batman in
the crime syndicate landscape it's not
that way instead Jim Gordon who's
normally the Commissioner of the police
commissioner
became a crime boss and when he did he
ordered the death of Martha Wayne Thomas
Wayne basically became the new police
commissioner
and the son who would normally be Bruce
Wayne is Thomas Wayne jr. and Thomas
Wayne jr. went on to become alum and the
other half of this is that we also pick
up with superwoman and it's kind of
crazy because super a super woman and
ala man are basically having an affair I
mean that's kind of the way things go
with them but superwoman is essentially
Wonder Woman except things changed up a
little bit so unlike Wonder Woman who
was who basically went on a mission of
sorts
to explore outside famous Kira
superwoman just left she adopted the
identity
of Lois Lane she's married to Ultraman
but she's cheating on him with Alan and
so their question is what in the world
is going on when it comes to you know
the whole idea of where Alexander Luthor
went and should we even be worried about
it because with Alexander Luthor being
like the the lone good guy he's
constantly trying to defeat them but
there's also a couple other characters
that were introduced here named power
ring and Johnny quick now again because
of the fact that this is a reboot of
sorts or a reimagining of the original
crime syndicate some liberties are taken
here with Grant Morrison for example the
original Johnny quick we basically know
none today uh nothing about him when he
first showed up all we knew is that he
has a helmet that gives him SuperSpeed
in this story it's not the same way is
essentially a concoction of sorts it's a
chemical that he takes that maintains
his SuperSpeed power ring is basically a
guy who's got the ring of voloom now
this will be the one instance in this
story where we referenced modern-day
events and DC Comics volthoom is a weird
concept so there were basically two
versions of voloom for years and years
and years and years you had both Foom
who was inside power range ring then you
had both Foom in DC Comics who was the
first Lantern in DC never never bridged
the gap between the two or at least they
didn't for quite some time what ended up
happening is when DC rebirth kicked off
writer Sam Humphreys came along and
bridged the gap what he basically said
is that in some far-off universe
somewhere both booms of world was
essentially coming to an end and so in
an attempt to find people that could
basically save his earth he and his
mother created the travel Lantern which
allows him to jump from one universe to
the next somewhere along the line he
ended up on the home universe of the
crime syndicate of America and what
ended up happening is like some monk out
there somewhere had basically taken a
fraction of all Foom soul and confined
it inside of a lantern so that that
power could be used but the whole idea
is that the character or the concept of
both Foom inside the ring that's used by
power ring is a fraction of the soul of
voloom the first Lantern so that was
something that didn't come along until
really like this year but at the time
this story was written with regards to
the original cowering character both
doom is just some presence inside of his
ring and ultimately he became a member
of the crime syndicate that's that's
really that's really all there is to it
something else that I want to point out
here is that when it comes to the
character of Johnny quick his energy
action of the substance that allows him
to run a super speed it's very much
drawn to the idea of a drug addiction
and that's why it's such a significant
thing because when Grant Morrison writes
stories he writes them in a way that
makes him tangible that makes him almost
relatable but there are you know there
are dark aspects about it and that's
really kind of how this is thrown in
there ultimately when the justice league
shows up in the crime syndicate universe
the first question is okay what's this
world like and as they go through all
they see are people who were just living
without any real measure of hope in a
world that is for the most part just
inherently violent now of course it's
also a Batman traveling directly to the
office of Thomas Wayne and what we end
up finding out is that where Thomas
Wayne is the police commissioner because
of the fact that everything on this
world is basically evil that almost all
the cops are extremely corrupt except
for like 30 of them who are loyal to
Thomas Wayne and that's about it but
that's like his inner circle
Batman's showing up in the office of
Thomas Wayne and essentially saying I'm
here to help it's kind of a crazy
scenario because this story fed directly
in and really influenced the events of
like DC rebirth and the button when
Batman met his father in the new 52
continuity for the first time so that's
one of the cool things that's why I say
Grant Morrison's stories are really in a
lot of ways the basis for other stories
that come along of course what he says
is the crime syndicates regime is over
in 48 hours everything's gonna be done
and that's because Alexander Luthor
calculated that out and his mind all
they need is a 48-hour window and 48
hours given the speed and the strength
and all the abilities of the members of
the Justice League they can basically
hold a crime syndicate prisoner and they
can in turn fix the world one of the
first acts that they make is to
basically have Kyle Rayner essentially
use his Green Lantern ring to subdue the
crime syndicate by blocking them off
creating a massive portal or a massive
force field of sorts around the moon and
then they can't get away and that's
really about it this basically allows
the Justice League to come along and say
we're going to make your world a better
place and they do this by basically
going to the president and saying look
the crime syndicates gonna be out of the
picture now you know you will be able to
essentially run your country the way a
government should we end up finding out
that when the United States and in
Britain went to war during the
Revolutionary War that were Benedict
Arnold actually declared war on Britain
that ultimately Britain was just kind of
devastated by the United States now
again this is another instance of the
differences between the crime syndicate
world and the main DC Universe but
notice this and that's the irony of all
this is that Superman
kind of makes us objection where he says
I mean are we really doing the right
thing here because what we're doing is
we're showing up on an alternate earth
and we're saying you guys need freedom
and what happens if people say well no
we don't want freedom oh the superheroes
gonna say yeah but like you need it
though we know it's good for you even if
you don't it's an extreme act of
arrogance the road to hell is paved with
good intentions and that's the nature of
that's kind of the message the grants a
grant morrison ascending but we begin to
find out there is a darker side when it
comes to this crime syndicate world
everything on this world is the opposite
of the main DC Universe and the main DC
Universe good is the way to go and the
crime syndicate world evil is the way to
go and that's the lesson the superheroes
begin to learn we're boss Gordon you
know Jim Gordon is basically to arrested
by Thomas Wayne senior and he's simply
just kind of sent off to jail you know
when it's all said and done and Batman
says now you have the ability to make
the world a better place
Thomas Wayne's response is yes I'm going
to do that and anybody who disagrees
with me is going to die and so that's
when Batman begins to realize this world
can't be fixed it's the natural order of
the world that evil will always prevail
that's what a low man figures out while
the crime syndicates being held captive
by the Justice League that is the
natural order of the world that evil
always comes out on top that even if you
show up and you do something good
people's response to that will be an
evil act they will basically say okay
cool instead of saying man you liberated
us and you saved us from these evil
people we're going to go ahead we're
gonna make the world a better place
instead their response is awesome you
got rid of those power-hungry people now
we can replace them and so because of
that ow man also comes to the conclusion
that essentially it's inevitable they're
going to swap places where the jet that
was used that showed up in the main DC
Universe with everybody on board who was
dead because that was something that
took 24 hours to complete the whole idea
of owl man is they're inevitably going
to switch places all they have to do is
jump back and that's what ends up
happening the crime syndicate just
vanishes from their captivity on the
moon and then when the questions asked
where did they go Lex Luthor everybody
else begins to realize they went back to
the main DC Universe and so they
effectively invade the main DC Universe
itself now their attack and their
attempt to subdue it it's pretty
short-lived you have off a man you have
like Martian Manhunter who respond it's
one of these cool scenarios because
Martian Manhunter ends up subduing
Ultraman so what we end up learning is
that Ultraman is basically powered by
anti kryptonite and what essentially
happened
is that this version was essentially a
guy named Clark Kent who was a pilot and
he kind of went on a mission in space he
was taken by aliens he was basically
reconstituted they enhanced him but it
drove him insane he arrived back on
earth calling himself Ultraman
essentially with Superman's powers the
problem with this is that instead of
being like Superman where he draws his
power from solar radiation from a Yellow
Sun Ultraman draws his power from anti
kryptonite the issue is that much like
Superman and a Yellow Sun the further
away Ultraman is from anti kryptonite
the weaker he gets and so as a result
his anti kryptonite is in a different
universe and so all he has left is
whatever powers inside of his body and
the more power he uses the more power he
loses and so with that in mind while he
does seem like he could successfully
face off against the Martian Manhunter
he ends up losing just because of the
fact that he's just draining his own
power he's draining his own energy and
so what we end up finding out here is
that where the flash is basically just
kind of powering this cyclotron more or
less that's going to be the means by
which the Justice League can jump back
to their reality we also end up finding
out that there was somebody else who was
working behind the scenes Alexander
Luthor begins asking the question why
did those Jets end up in those realities
in the first place why did a jet from
the positive you know from the the main
DC Universe end up in the crime
syndicate universe and why did a jet
from the crime syndicate universe end up
in the DC universe did somebody send
them there and that's the conclusion
that he runs to that somebody was
testing out whether or not this
interdimensional portal device would
work and the person who was testing it
was Brainiac and so that's why this is
cool is because what we end up finding
out here is that Brainiac as he exists
on the on the crime syndicate world is
essentially a servant of Ultraman but
that Brainiac was captured by Ultraman
when he was just kind of perusing the
universe the antimatter universe Amon
was ultimately used as kind of like this
source of knowledge and information and
so on and so forth to make the best
possible decisions in terms of logic and
reason and so on but while Brainiac was
serving as this sort of errand boy to
Ultraman to his intelligence was
constantly evolving until he basically
saw it as the best opportunity to lead
and much like Skynet going live in the
Terminator universe
Brainiac just starts spreading
throughout essentially the digital
sphere itself and so what he starts
doing is merging the earth three
universe and the main DC Universe into
one trying to converge them into a
singular universe to do whatever it is
that he wants to do you know trying to
merge the earths together and so of
course the Justice League
comes to realize that because of the
fact that this time syndicate world
cannot be safe they do the only thing
they can do which is in order to defeat
Brainiac to walk away to basically just
say we're going to leave this earth to
its fate there's nothing we can do at
the same time we end up having this
moment where the Justice League is sent
back to their own universe the crime
syndicate is yanked back to their earth
that Ultraman was also told by oh man
that's what's going on here Brainiac is
the one that tricked us into this and so
with Ultraman arriving on the scene what
he ends up doing is basically zapping
and and more or less lobotomizing
Brainiac but that's the nature of this
story the whole idea of JLA earth 2 was
not to just tell a story worse the crime
syndicate versus the Justice League and
who's gonna win it was basically
designed to say that there is such a
thing as hopelessness that there is such
a thing as a world out there where the
day cannot be saved not because they
faced insurmountable odds in terms of
some enemy who is super strong or super
fast or something like that but because
the earth itself doesn't want to be
fixed it is a social critique on society
it's Grant Morrison sitting down and
saying there's a difference between
people who say they want things to
change and people who believe they want
things to change that doing things
changes things doing nothing keeps
things exactly as they are and that's
the point that he makes that there are
people out there who just don't want
things to change
there for whatever reason they just want
to live and you know anger and sadness
and squalor and you know just be
miserable and with those folks they
can't be changed no matter what you do
they will not leave that mindset they
will stay in that mindset forever there
is no saving them they're beyond
redemption whereas in the main DC
universe people do want a better
tomorrow people do want to look to the
future they look to the horizon and want
to believe that things can be better
than they are and that's the inherent
difference sometimes a Justice League
just can't win sometimes the enemy they
face is not an opponent it's an ideology
and you cannot defeat an ideology so
long as people genuinely want to believe
it but with that being said guys where
you go ahead and bring this video to an
end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah
definitely one of my favorite Justice
League stories out there I think it's
beautifully done it's super cool it's
really really interesting and yeah we're
gonna bring this video to an end and
I'll catch you all later
peace
[Music]